wow uh welcome welcome to the show
everybody uh the last 24 hours
in american politics are the craziest 24
hours i've ever been involved with
with from the standpoint of of covering
them and we had
um i think six hours of live streams
yesterday
in addition to the broadcast show and
the bonus show
and uh almost an impossibility to even
keep up with what is going on so today's
show is going to be very different than
any show we've done
we are in a sense we are winging it and
what i mean by that is
um i have about 13 or 14 different
stories that i would like to talk about
today
um and we may get to all of them and we
may not in other words
i'm starting today not with every minute
planned as we normally have
uh but with an idea of the things we
should discuss
and we'll just jump into them and i hope
i know a lot of you have been emailing
me saying i can't keep up
well we we haven't been able to keep up
either so let's try to do
justice to the last 24 hours because the
historical significance really cannot be
overstated um let's start with what
happened yesterday yesterday
january 6th was meant to be the day
during which there would be a merely
ceremonial counting of the electoral
votes which were cast on december 14th
in the november election joe biden won
via popular vote
in the 50 u.s states winning some losing
some getting enough electoral votes
to become president on december 14th the
electors in all 50 states
certified their uh state's election
and on january 6th those ballots already
having been cast on december 14th
a joint session of the house and senate
led by vice president mike pence as
president of the senate was to
simply count those votes now we knew
there would be some chaos
because for two months donald trump has
been insisting without evidence that he
actually won
that it was rigged that he wants uh this
state to be overturned that he wants
that state to be overturned that there
were massive
dumps of ballots that mike pence needs
to do the right
thing and that something and it wasn't
just trump but many of his
most sycophantic supporters who were
hoping
planning believing that something would
happen yesterday
that would prevent joe biden from being
determined in that joint session by mike
pence
the winner of the 2020 election now i'll
skip to the end
it happened it was delayed by a few
hours but it happened and we will get to
that
but what we imagined would simply be
some debate
we knew there would be senators and
members of the house on the republican
side standing up
and objecting to the the counting of
ballots from certain states
arizona for example pennsylvania and
others we knew that would happen
we expected there would be a couple of
hours of debate for each of those
objections
but that ultimately republicans didn't
have the vote to hold up even
a single state's votes from being
counted and that
it might be 10 pm it might be 1 a.m it
might be 3 a.m it might be this morning
or later today
eventually they would run out of
objections they would run out of votes
and that would be it but something else
happened
something else happened which is that in
the morning donald trump
incited an insurrectionist mob
to march down pennsylvania avenue
to the capitol building and wreak havoc
uh break down doors and destroy
windows commit property crimes fight
with police
some police actually injured and this
was
fomented directly by donald trump and
this is not to say that many of these
folks didn't have this idea going into
yesterday already
but i am going to show you how donald
trump did this donald trump
literally told them what to do and later
said
oh b please be peaceful but we will get
to that here is donald trump at this
wacky event i don't know what they were
calling it it was a steal the election
rally essentially
here is trump again saying mike pence
you'd better do the right thing
the left knows exactly what they're
doing
they're ruthless and it's time that
somebody did something about it and mike
pence i hope you're going to stand up
for the good
of our constitution and for the good
of our country and if you're not i'm
going to be very disappointed in you i
will tell you right now
i'm not hearing good stories ultimately
donald trump ended up denouncing his own
vice president mike pence and we will
get to that later
donald trump continuing to fire up the
crowd by saying the caravans are forming
remember those caravans
that up until the day before the 2018
midterms
were every day in right-wing media the
caravans of dangerous hispanic
immigrants are coming
2018 midterms happen we don't hear about
the caravans ever again until yesterday
here is trump ginning up more uh uh hate
by saying the caravans are forming
because they know biden will let them in
but now the caravans they think biden's
getting in the caravans are forming
again
they want to come in again and rip off
our country can't let it happen
and then here is donald trump just
literally telling them what to do saying
we're going to march up pennsylvania
avenue we're going to go to the capitol
he said he told them what to do and they
did it take a look
we're going to walk down pennsylvania
avenue i love pennsylvania avenue
and we're going to the capitol and we're
going to try
and give the democrats are hopeless
they're never voting for anything
not even one vote but we're going to try
and give
our republicans the weak ones because
the strong ones don't need any of our
help
we're going to try and give them the
kind of pride
and boldness that they need to take back
our country
so let's walk down pennsylvania avenue
i want to thank you all god bless you
and god
bless america thank you all for being
here this is incredible thank you very
much
thank you
[Music]
and that is exactly that is exactly what
they did
while we were covering what i thought
would just be
really boring debate for hour after hour
about republican objections to the
counting of ballots from certain states
we saw live and we saw we had over 1.1
million different people
watch at least some piece of our live
stream yesterday we all saw
with with horror most of us uh as
the angry mob of trumpists became
angrier and angrier fighting with police
eventually overwhelming law enforcement
and there are many questions about how
that happened
where where was law enforcement and
there are there's everything from
speculation to conspiracy theories to
mere belief of incompetence and at some
point we will sort that out
overwhelming law enforcement breaking
into the capital leading to mike pence
being taken out of there by by a secret
service
leading to house and senate leadership
being taken sort of in protective
custody or
you know by security to safe safe
locations
an evacuation of the house and senate
chambers protesters and mobsters and
rioters i don't even know what to call
them
broke into nancy pelosi's office uh and
they they did they did exactly what
would be on the logical end of two
months of firing people up with lies
culminating with trump saying at 12 30
p.m
half an hour before this all started
we're going to march over
down pennsylvania ave to the capitol
eventually
after things got completely out of
control and i know i'm not going to get
every detail right
or i'm not going to get every detail
into the story
discussions about do we deploy the
national guard reports that trump
resisted but ultimately mike pence made
the decision to deploy
the national guard trump seemingly not
wanting to deploy the national guard
against his own
supporters and eventually donald trump
uploaded a video
saying to people it's time to go home he
says
you're great people we love you it was
stolen
it was a landslide then we actually went
but it's time to go home
and that video was ultimately uh
locked by twitter later removed removed
by facebook i didn't even find it on
youtube unclear whether they uploaded
and it was removed
it was a video uh essentially
defending the feelings and the actions
but saying it's time to go home
and repeating the exact same stuff that
jinned up the the anger
in the first place trump then also
tweeted basically a defense of the
rioters as he told them to go home
this was also removed by twitter donald
trump saying these are the things and
events that happen
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away from great patriots
who have been badly and unfairly treated
for so long he is saying
this is what happens when you steal the
election from me it makes sense that
this is what's happening and then he
adds
go home with love and in peace remember
this day forever uh also
ultimately removed from twitter
trump defending the actions of the
violent writers while sort of staying
saying go home so we're going to talk
about
reaction to this and the discussion of
the removal of donald trump
we will of course cover the fact that
biden did get the votes yesterday
there are rumors that will there will be
more rioting today and very important
there were only as of now
52 arrests yesterday even though there
were clearly hundreds if not thousands
of people
who trespassed did property damage uh
attacked police broke the law in many
different ways the fbi
has said it is a priority to identify
every single person who did that
so i i'm not going to call names out
specifically on this show
but there are known right-wing activists
and
and nuts who are pictured inside the
capitol
and and committing crimes trespassing
etc
um let's help the fbi there should be
hundreds if not thousands of arrests
from what happened yesterday
and there have only been 52 as of five
minutes ago so
let's let's actually uh uh make justice
be done because
these are folks who deserve a criminal
record we talk about someone holding
uh you know hold holding a tiny amount
of cannabis
who ends up with a criminal record and
how insane that is
these are folks who deserve criminal
records okay so let's do what we can to
make that happen
so it's a new year and for many people
that means new
goals around getting fit or losing
weight and if part of that for you
involves a low-carb or ketogenic diet
then i have something you will want to
check out it's called
so keto-licious and they're giving you
20 percent off
soaky delicious has perfected ketogenic
crusts for baking your favorite
foods they make a delicious keto dessert
crust which comes in a chocolate and
vanilla flavor and it's perfect for
making things like pies they also have a
premium keto pizza crust which i've been
using at home to make pizzas and it's
great
it is great to go right out of the
freezer
and when you cook it it doesn't fall
apart like a lot of other low carb
crusts do
it's high fat which is perfect for keto
grain free gluten free no soy or
additives or
preservatives or fillers but most
importantly
they just taste great i can tell you
first hand just go to davidpakman.com
pizza the link is underneath this video
and they'll give you 20
off your entire order when you use the
coupon code pacman